- Les changements climatiques
n'est pas épargné. Au cours
des derniers mois la tempête
Fiona a secoué les Îles-de-la-
Madeleine. Un déluge s'est
un derecho a déferlé sur
le Québec, causant de nombreux
dégâts. Ce dernier événement,
à lui seul, a coûté plus
Hydro-Québec. Mais surtout,
laissé plus de 550 000enenents
du réseau sans électricité,
et certains pendant
jours. Hydro-Québec a donc
dévoilé un plan d'ononon qui
va de la gestion des pannes
des techniciens sur le terrain.
PHILIPPE BOURKE, dir. ac
dévelop. durable, Hydro-Québec
- On a tous s s dû jongler
avec les aléas, les caprices
de dame Nature. Là, ce qu'on
la science du climat, c'est
que riririsques-là changent,
s'accroissent, sont plus
variables.
- La société d'État
veut notamment remplacer
en bois, fragilisés en cas
de chaleur extrême, par d'autres
en composite plus résitants.
en cours dans la région de
l'Outaouais afin d'évaluer les
bienfaits et le inconvénients
de
DOMINIQUE FORGET,
mairesse de Val-David
- C'est une bonne nouvelle.
C'est important qu'on cesse de
puise qu'on se rende compte
qu'il y a des effets sur
les changements climatiques.
- Hydro-Québec veut aussi :
ÉLOÏSE EDOM, associée recherche,
Inst. énergie Trottier
- Où on est rendus dans
nos efforts de décarbonation
d'avoir quelque chose
peut-être d'un peu p
consistant en terme de
quantité d'information.
- Comme c'est déjà
la société d'État envisage
aussi l'enfouissement
de câbles électriques
pour pUDUDUDUDUDUDUDUDUDUDUDUDUs
techno., Hydro-Québec
- On fait actuellement
un projet-pilote au Parc
de la Mauricie. Actuelle
envisage pour des sections
rurales, peu de clie
très boisés, difficiles d'accès
où là les coûts peuvent devenir
compétitifs à lananananananananx
aériens.
- Cette option serait toutefois
4 à 5 fois plus coûteuse
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Ra,a,a,a,a,a, Montréa